hello freak [ __ ] areas el Heath pre
jacked yep he's a Phil Heath his you
know giant is not very wide in the
shoulders that's his weak point but he's
got huge long muscle bellies on most of
his body is pecs are not great but the
rest you know the rest is a it doesn't
really have any weak points that's why
is is ahead of everybody else and you
just think there's less people doing it
now there's less people going into
competitive bodybuilding because a lot
more avenues and I think it's less
popular now because it's almost like
peaked out with myself and run in and
gone down a little bit it's like how do
you you know how do you surpass it got
to a peak and guys are trying to do that
so that they you know that they're
trying to get big and they're getting
big but they're getting big with a big
waste and everything as well so it's not
the same it's not the same look it's not
they're not the same quality I've got to
be super dangerous isn't it when you see
those guys those enormous bloated
bellies yeah it's a huge debate and like
what is that you know what is it I don't
know is it internal organs as well
here's the thing initially that's what
people fought right and I my way started
get a little bloated around 96 97
maybe 97 when I was using insulin I got
a little bloated a little distended but
when I retired it went down and I
actually in England well because I was
always like I'm taking steroids for this
sport because I'm a professional when
I'm not completing I'm going to take
them so stop taking them and also I took
growth hormone and that was a thing a
lot of people think growth hormone is
going to increase the size of internal
organs and that's why guys are getting
bloated waistline so I went and had a
real I mean a battery of tests where
they actually measure all your internal
organs and mine are all totally normal I
fight from my heart was a bit bigger and
stronger but that's just normal
athletic heart so that wasn't the case
so I perhaps it's fat that's building up
around internal organs or maybe it's
just a lot of water in the in test
just blow to the waste out short answer
is the short answer is I don't really
know who's that guy in the far left
that's like a turtle shell doesn't only
a turtle shell
yeah Jesus Christ so that could be
insulin it could be a variety only seen
this kind of thing happening since the
guys are using insulin and igf-1
insulin-like growth factor Wow
so yeah it's not a good looks not a you
know weird the turtle show look is so
weird it literally looks like so it's
like the guys have got big like but
everywhere systemic like growth you know
when you train with whites you you know
you major muscles are going to grow but
not around the waist confliction a
little bit but not that much
now when you got off of everything yeah
retired what was the crash like well
wasn't something I was ready for I had a
lot of things going in my life I had a
divorce
I had a somebody close to me pass away
and I'm you know retiring so you know
they say a death in the family or
divorce or retirement is like major
stressful event about an or [ __ ]
three at the same time while you're not
while you're coming down from steroids
so yeah I definitely suffer from
depression anxiety like I know what's
going on like why do I feel like this I
didn't even like now I know where
because you [ __ ] cut stop cold turkey
because that I'm extreme I'm like I'm
using them because I'm doing this I'm
stop now and stop so and I had no real
help there was no real like this guys
now in especially in the states that you
know they they specialize in you
patients that are using steroids and all
you know possible side effects and
coming off and all that stuff I don't
really have any of that so I just went
cold turkey and after about two years my
normal testosterone was still not coming
into the normal so then I went on the
replacement therapy which is like twice
a month testosterone replacement and
yeah then I felt normal again
[Applause]
[Music]